raised his hands and then I'll stood up
at once 10 2007 the biggest army in the
world it's what you're going to do I
want to hope they don't learn how to
climb the wall but the dragonglass
no one's ever getting that back now it
wouldn't have mattered anyway unless
really mountain of it but you killed a
white Walker long haul some shatter
steel axes leather a glass but Lanka is
Valyrian steel
how many for nailing steel swords are
left in the Seven Kingdoms no enough
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
7 prediction video today I want to talk
about something that I've been asked
about since I first started making
videos which is the Valyrian steel sword
dark sister there is a photo that I've
used a Brandon mirror several times in
my videos and every time I use it I'm
always asked about this sword so I
figured I would finally make a video and
talk about this I have gray area here
with me today to give you all a little
bit of a back story on this famous
Valyrian steel sword black sister is one
of the two Targaryen ancestral Valyrian
steel swords the sword itself is famous
and has been in the Targaryen family
since before Aegon conquered Westeros
it once belonged to Aegon sister-wife
visenya targaryen dark sister was also
wielded by Damon the rogue Prince and he
leaped from his dragon caraxes and stuck
dark sister through the good eye of
Prince Aemon Targaryen during the dance
of dragons the last known owner of dark
sister was the three-eyed Raven Brynden
rivers bastard Targaryen if you look
closely to this photo you will see what
I believe is dark sister laying against
the tree
we know Mira didn't go to the three-eyed
crow with a sword she carried a bow in
her frog spear you're absolutely right
bloodraven was the last person known to
be in possession of this Valyrian steel
sword and he has most likely headed in
the cave with him this entire time when
Brandon Mira first arrived right
the cave they were attacked by some
skeleton looking whites and after
fighting them for a few minutes Hodor
picked up brain and ran inside the cave
when he did this neither one of them was
carrying a sword and neither was Mira
when she ran inside the only thing we
saw in her hands at the time was the
dagger that she used to give Joe Jin a
quick death since he was badly injured
they spent a significant amount of time
at the three-eyed Ravens cave while bran
was in training
eventually brain went wandering into a
green dream by himself and that's when
he was touched by the night king which
then allowed the night king to track
brain down the mark also allowed the
night king to enter the cave that once
had a magical fortress to keep him out
the night king and his army showed up at
the cave and that's when the night king
tested its magical protection which was
now gone when mirror ran into the cave
she grabbed the sword that was laying
against the wall next to a bunch of
dragonglass spears she ended up taking
his sword with her when they fled the
cave it's the same sword we see in this
photo while they are with Benjen Stark
and I know something you may be thinking
it's not a beautiful looking sword like
some of the other Valyrian steel swords
that we've seen but you have to keep in
mind this sword would have been in the
three-eyed Ravens dark and dirty cave
for decades they may have even
foreshadowed the introduction of this
sword all the way back in season 2
Rhaenys rode meraxes
señor Vega until I knew that my name is
a boy
Sonya Targaryen was a great warrior she
had a Valyrian steel sword she called
dark sister
since a heroine of yours I take most
girls more interested in the pretty
maidens from the songs junkie flowers in
their head most girls are idiots huh
you remind me of my daughter I need to
learn all this stuff about Visenya and
her Valyrian steel sword my father it's
interesting that REO stark would be the
one to talk about a sword called dark
sister
the path that aria has been on
definitely reflects that of a dark
sister in my opinion she would be the
perfect person to carry a sword like
this in fact when I first thought this
could be that Valyrian steel sword I
imagined that Arya Stark would end up
being the one to wield it but after the
photos from Entertainment Weekly came
out showing Arya with the Valyrian steel
dagger I'm not so sure she would get
this sword now too
because she still has needle also
although needle was just a Castleford
steel but this is the perfect time to
introduce this sword now that they are
bringing all the other ones back in the
play we haven't seen this Valyrian steel
dagger since season 1 but here it is
with Arya Stark right before season 7
begins and we had never seen Hart's Bane
before either until just a few episodes
ago when Sam Tarly took it from his
father's mantle at horn Hill widow's
wail also disappeared from the show for
a few seasons too but after HBO released
some new photos we now know Jaime
Lannister has disorder with them it's
not a coincidence all the Valyrian steel
was coming back into the plot the long
night is upon us
winter is here and the White Walkers
come with it all this Valyrian steel
will make its way to the war Sam will
make his way back north with Hearts Bane
Jon Snow is in the North now with long
haul Breanna's in the north - with
Oathkeeper and the dagger is in the
north most likely with Littlefinger but
soon to be Arya I even think Jaime
Lannister will eventually make his way
north - with what as well and now we
have dark sister the famous sword of
House Targaryen
do you remember what benjin said to
Brandon mirror right before he left them
I was going to controlling for the night
King comes he will find his way to the
will of men when he does you will be
there waiting fine and you will be ready
brain and mirror make it south of the
wall but they will meet the night king
and the White Walkers again and when
they do they're going to need protection
they need a Valyrian steel sword so this
is definitely the perfect time to
introduce this Valyrian steel sword
because without it mirror read does not
stand a chance of protecting brain any
longer with the war for the dawn on the
horizon Westeros will need all the
dragon glass and Valyrian steel swords
they can get their hands on and who
knows maybe Arya Stark does end up with
the sword that she was always so very
fond of dark sister does fit her
identity very well in my opinion but
what do you all say do you believe that
this is the Valyrian steel sword dark
sister and if you do who do you think
will be the one to wield it in the wars
to come who would you like to see carry
this into battle let me know your
thoughts on this thanks for stopping by
and watching the video I appreciate you
taking the time out of your day to check
it out don't forget to subscribe the
gray areas channel she makes a bunch of
great content over there that I think
you will enjoy thank you to all my
patreon supporters also I love you all
and I'll see you down below bye